welcome back whether it's back to school
or back to work floyd's barber shop is
going to give you the good hair you've
been looking for and now they're doing
it for a good cause let's welcome justin
the owner and allison she's one of the
stylists welcome to show you guys good
afternoon awesome thanks for being here
so tell us why why are you giving back
why did you decide to do this sure so um
myself and my brother were the
franchisees for floyd's and we've been
involved actually in jdrf for a long
time um it's with board activity and
just involved in the community
uh the founders of floyd's actually one
of them rob has a daughter with type one
when we started doing this business
didn't really even know that about each
other found out and discovered and then
on top of it they've been raising money
at all their locations for the last 10
years about and so over 2 million
dollars to date has gone to help support
type 1 diabetes research you guys do
amazing things so how does it work how
do people get involved how do they help
out
well in our locations we have
coupon booklets that we are handing out
a cooking show but we don't have these
we have coupon books in here oh okay and
then if yeah so any amount they start at
five dollars and then you can donate any
number of amounts and that actually in
the coupon book if you do that there's
over 35 bucks worth of stuff this is
cool so we have this coupon book so you
buy this and it's how you get your
discounts with haircuts and also get
back to the charity exactly five bucks
everyone we've had some really generous
people that have left even more than
that when they've come in but uh you're
gonna get your money back and then some
on the service side of things now
sometimes when people come in and we're
talking about hairstyles and everything
they bring scissors or you guys didn't
bring scissors what did you bring today
what is this you've been running around
like a madman for this show so we
appreciate that and we know how it's
stressful times in the world so
at the end of every single service that
we do you get an old-school uh massage
shoulder massage for us so we can you
know you know i don't know how much time
you got or what you got to do here next
but you might be having to call in sick
or get a little bit lazy how does this
work this happens
so every service yeah
you know we specialize in men's cuts but
we also do women color services eyes
nose eyebrow wax and holding but no
matter what you do you're going to get
one of these things for about five
minutes great and i'm helping out a
charity absolutely i did notice the
facial hair you have okay i got some
facial hair as well can people uh want a
beard trim also help out the costume you
know we we lay you back we get the
lather on we're doing a hot towel we're
doing some barber style services on you
so whether it i mean honestly i'm not
going to get too graphic almost every
hair on your body can be tended and
taken care of at floyd's but we're going
to make you look good i love it thank
you guys so much thank you for joining
us and real quick what's the website
when people want to talk about
99.com just www.floyds99.com
easy enough rocky we'll send it over to
you let's continue the massage